Let's code this in Java. I can see here
that I have the number of students and the
number of topics and the two-dimensional array of grades.
I can ignore the student names and the topics for
now. What I'm really interested in is implementing the
total for student method. To do this, the important thing
to recognize is that I want to access all of
the grades in one row. The grades in one row
all share their first index, but their second index
varies because that tells which column. So I'll loop
over all of the columns starting at the first
one and since there's a column for each topic, I'll
keep going as long as my column is less
than the number of topics. I'll need a variable to
hold the sum. And for each item, I'll add
the grade in the studentIndex row in the column column.
And when I'm done, I'll return the sum. Just
to be safe, if somebody gives me a bad studentIndex.
I want to return minus one. So if studentIndex is less
than zero or greater than or equal to the number
of students, I return minus one. This is always a
good idea when somebody else is calling your method. You
want to think about the things that they could do wrong,
and agree on a good way to handle those cases.